[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta edición especial
de revista digital las medidas de
confinamiento destinadas a frenar el
brote de kobe 19 en el mundo reformaron
la manera en la que nos comunicamos
trabajamos estudiamos y hasta cómo
socializamos y nos ejercitamos una gran
parte de la población se vio obligada a
migrar a la virtualidad para seguir su
cotidianidad pero la pandemia también
expuso las desigualdades entre quienes
tienen la facilidad de acceder a
internet y quienes ni siquiera cuentan
con una computadora como nos ha ido en
este 2020 virtual empezamos
en materia laboral 2020 fue un año
difícil para muchas familias que
perdieron sus fuentes de ingreso a raíz
del confinamiento y cierre de negocios
no esenciales
unas medidas sin precedentes y
destinadas a frenar los contagios de
kobe 19 y si perder sus ingresos
cotidianos ha sido catastrófico para
muchos encerrarse en casa tampoco ha
sido fácil una gran parte de la
población se sumergió de manera masiva
en el teletrabajo esta modalidad ya
existía pero antes sólo era una entre
muchas opciones en los últimos meses se
convirtió casi en una obligación según
expertos el teletrabajo ha traído
consigo ansiedad sentimientos de soledad
síntomas de depresión y estrés debido a
que fue un cambio abrupto
crazy fernández es madre de dos niños ha
estado al tanto de la educación de sus
hijos que se lleva a cabo de forma
remota pero además ha tenido que cumplir
con su jornada laboral desde
barranquilla colombianos contó que ha
sido lo más difícil de esta nueva etapa
que se ha extendido por cerca de un año
hay algo más que va más allá es es la
parte emocional fue para mí lo más
difícil de leer que sentirme bien yo
porque es que a la larga uno mamá
trabajando ser profesora atender la casa
atender el hogar
el esposo entonces de verdad que es
demasiado duro tener que sentirse uno
bien para poder de darle a todos mi
jornada empieza desde las cinco que me
levanto para ir al gimnasio porque
aparte pues también entro yo un huevo
importante que soy yo como toda diciendo
usa primero sentir hacer sentir bien a
los demás pero también sentirte bien
contigo mismo entonces desde las 5 de la
mañana en el gimnasio llegar corriendo
alistarte para listar a los niños tipo c
y media para que a las 7 estuvieran
sentados dando la clase y mejor nada
pues termina siendo mamá a las 9 de la
noche cuando acuesto a los niños a
dormir
la mayoría de quienes trabajan desde
casa alegan que sus jornadas laborales
se han extendido más de lo habitual una
situación que ha llevado a que los
empleados aborrezcan su trabajo y a sus
jefes consultamos a constanza núñez ella
es psicóloga y coach laboral en santiago
de chile- quien nos recomendó cómo
evitar una relación tóxica con nuestro
trabajo
qué importante andrés lo que comentas
porque es lo que pasó que como partimos
el teletrabajo sin tenerlo muy
delimitado los horarios y todos partimos
con el teletrabajo sin saber cuál es mi
horario inicio los límites frente a esto
y muchos jefes también no tenían
conciencia de que si bien estábamos la
casa trabajando también teníamos que
ocuparnos los niños hacer las tareas
domésticas y ver otros temas que también
tienen que ver con el autocuidado
entonces efectivamente yo tengo muchos
clientes que me decían que la jornada
laboral era más extensa de lo que antes
tenían entonces no había un término y en
ese sentido claramente el estrés o
aumenta o por supuesto y en ese sentido
yo lo que recomiendo es tener primero un
lugar de trabajo acorde a la
circunstancia mucha gente estaba
trabajando en el mismo lugar de descanso
y que su pieza entonces eso significa
que cuando yo me voy a acostar tampoco
tengo un límite de donde sigo preocupada
a todos los temas laborales entonces
también importante tener un espacio
físico que sea acorde para trabajar y
tener un horario inicio y término que
tiene que ver con poner límites también
y el autocuidado y hablar con tu
jefatura
o sea negociable el término la jornada
que puedes cerrar tu computador y
después empezar a hacer tus tareas
personales tu hobby o descansar
solamente entonces efectivamente esa
parte tóxica ha hecho que la gente se
motive mucho más en su trabajo y el
estrés aumente considerablemente
constanza también nos habló de las
lecciones que nos ha dejado esta
emergencia
yo creo que la lección más importante de
la pandemia con el teletrabajo es pensar
que si nos podemos adaptar al cambio
somos seres constantes evolución pero si
no podemos descuidar la salud mental y
eso tiene que ver mucho con preocuparnos
nuestro autocuidado si bien tenemos
jornada laboral hay que buscar descansos
entre medio en tener rutinas de
autocuidado que sean ejercicios
meditación un descanso por lo menos de
ocho horas para poder comenzar la nueva
jornada y una alimentación adecuada
entonces no hay que descuidar la salud
mental sobre todo en este aspecto porque
si sin ese sin esa base no podemos
disfrutar ni el trabajo nuestras
familias nuestra área personal las
aplicaciones más utilizadas para
actividades como el teletrabajo han sido
google mit microsoft y skype y zoom esta
última es una de las más descargadas del
mundo y su alta demanda ha hecho que la
compañía se valoriza a niveles récord la
acción de zoom que cerró en 2019 en 68
dólares en la bolsa de nueva york en los
últimos días de diciembre se cotizaba en
alrededor
a 400 dólares es decir que en tan solo
un año se multiplicó por 6 según el new
york stock exchange
la acción de microsoft cerró en 2019 con
un valor de 157 dólares y alcanzó este
diciembre los 219 dólares mientras que
la acción de google pasó de mil 339 a
finales de diciembre de 2019 a alcanzar
los mil 740 dólares en diciembre de este
año
esta y otras aplicaciones también fueron
útiles para la educación debido al
cierre de escuelas aunque no han sido
las únicas herramientas utilizadas fuera
de las aulas para no detener el año
escolar los gobiernos han implementado
distintas estrategias desde clases por
whatsapp en costa de marfil hasta
cátedras mediáticas como el uso de la
televisión en méxico y cuba y la radio
en sudán del sur y en el campo
colombiano para poder continuar con las
clases
pero estas nuevas modalidades de
enseñanza también nos han planteado
nuevos desafíos en octubre pasado
decenas de medios de comunicación de
américa latina registraron la noticia de
un profesor que se que impartía clases
en línea y se mostró frustrado ante la
falta de atención de sus estudiantes el
video se hizo viral al instante vean por
qué y si este momento quien no tengo
ganas de enseñar es porque mañana más
saber que nuestro profesor no me enseñó
nada es que no te enseñan en problemas
que tú no leíste nadie ustedes estudian
estoy harto el problema de ustedes todo
el país van a confiar la gente a ustedes
sus problemas y no estudia no es
problema de ustedes no es problema de
docente estoy viendo la posibilidad de
la próxima semana renunciar y mediando
con mi conciencia tranquila gracias
alumnos hasta el hasta nunca se trata de
juan francisco valdeón ríos docente de
derecho minero en la facultad de derecho
de la universidad nacional federico
villarreal en perú y con quien hablamos
desde la capital peruana en lima
valdeón detalló los desafíos que plantea
la educación en línea tanto para los
educadores
como para los estudiantes
en principio yo pienso que es la
motivación
el estudiante tiene que estar
completamente motivado pero esa
motivación no parte propiamente del por
parte del docente sino también tiene
como frente como preocupación es el
acompañamiento por parte de los padres
de familia aquí en este proceso de
aprendizaje online es frío
porque el estudiante y el docente no
percibe las emociones del estudiante
mientras uno va explicando
simultáneamente es complicado que el
cerebro trabaja también para estar
leyendo el simultáneo los chats entonces
es por eso que no debemos perder este
calor transmitir o hacerlo posible
transmitir el calor entre estudiantes o
esas emociones entre estudiantes y
docentes de ida y de retorno
desde la educación primaria hasta la
universidad
las clases en línea llegaron sin avisar
a américa latina y el caribe una región
donde el acceso a internet de evidencia
una brecha digital son las consecuencias
de una pandemia que amenaza con marcar
un antes y un después en la educación
veamos el informe de uan pupiales la
foto de alexander contreras se hizo
viral en el salvador este estudiante
universitario tiene que subirse a los
árboles para conseguir señal para su
teléfono y atender a sus clases en línea
la imagen llegó al gobierno de nadie
bukele a prometer la existencia como
álex otros estudiantes en zonas rurales
de este país también se ven obligados a
ingeniárselas para estar conectados
llegando a colgar sus celulares en el
aire en búsqueda de la ansiada red si
hablamos de la educación virtual hay que
hablar de internet bien américa latina'
esto evidencia una brecha digital
aproximadamente dos tercios de la
población tiene acceso a la red según
naciones unidas pero con escenarios tan
distintos como el de chile en donde el
80% de la población puede entrar a
internet frente al 25 por ciento de
nicaragua son los fundadores pero en la
educación virtual no tiene marcha atrás
según el periodista y profesor juan
carlos salazar de la universidad
católica boliviana que reconoce las
dificultades que hay en su país a la
hora de acceder a internet hay muchas
familias que no tienen el internet en su
casa y si lo tienen tienen un solo
computador donde además de la educación
virtual de los hijos los padres o los
hermanos mayores
deben trabajar también a distancia pero
hay que tener en cuenta que la enseñanza
virtual ha llegado para quedarse y vamos
a hacer muy bien en adaptarnos cuanto
antes
para lucia el cambio no ha sido difícil
con 15 años esta adolescente argentina
está en el penúltimo curso de secundaria
antes de llegar a la universidad es como
que estoy más organizada con las cosas
porque tengo todavía en la computadora y
[Música]
y si no tiene claro que estudiar le
gusta la administración de la economía
una carrera que afrontará tras una
fuerte huella dejada por el cob y 19
sobre la educación universal desde el
ocio hasta el deporte los cumpleaños las
fechas especiales la llamada nueva
normalidad nos tocó a todos despedimos
este especial de revista digital con las
imágenes que por sí solas cuentan cómo
nos cambió la vida
[Música]
así despedimos esta edición de revista
digital recuerda que si quieres repetir
este u otro episodio de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web triple